ja wir machen ja etwas was sehr
ungewöhnlich ist wir machen ein
sondervermögen 100 milliarden euro für
die bundeswehr und da könnte man auf die
idee kam sozialdemokraten 100 milliarden
ja bisher auch dann lebendigkeit und
dann ein linker der hier setzt das auch
noch richtig findet und er findet das
aus zwei gründen richtig finde es ist
richtig weil wenn man eine
parlamentsarmee haben die bundeswehr ist
das dann darf man die nicht runter
kommen lassen dann darf man nicht sagen
die amerikaner übernehmen 80 jahren nach
dem krieg noch unsere verteidigung wir
haben steht für die nicht mehr als
tauglichen flugzeuge die nicht fliegen
fahrzeuge die nicht fahren keine
nachtsichtgeräte sind wirklich ganz
bescheiden ausgestattet das muss man
ändern und zweitens
das soll nach mögen stellt sicher dass
wir in der zeit wo wir das machen müssen
zueinander ist der bündnisverteidigung
wir das nicht zu lasten des machen wofür
wir gewählt worden sind nämlich wir
wollten nichts cdu politik machen
sondern wir wollten klimaschutz machen
wir wollten in bildung investieren wir
wollen digitalisierung machen wir wollen
den sozialstaat gerechter machen und
kinder konnte sich auch mal an solche
dinge da wir eine schuldenbremse haben
geht das aber nur mit dem sondervermögen
das heißt sondervermögen aber es geht
eben nämlich schön war mit die union
werde was haben das nicht mitmachen und
der springende punkt ist jetzt dass alle
verstehen es geht nicht um aufrüstung
sodass geht darum die ausrüstung zu
verbessern ist und von lamprecht dass
ich mal sagen verdammt recht wird ja
nicht kritisiert wegen ihrer
stöckelschuhe oder weil sie an oster
urlaub macht sondern weil sie den
größten konzern an die wäsche gehen wer
diesen wir haben nämlich geld hatten wir
genug beschaffungsskandale
managementposten teure gutachten und die
würden am liebsten was auf ihrem hof vom
ort zu bestpreisen verkaufen aber so
funktioniert darf das nicht vollständig
gerüstet zu sein haben zu entscheiden
sondern die politik da muss kräftig
dazwischen gefahren werden und wir
brauchen wir europäische zusammenarbeit
aus denn die nato gibt deutlich mehr
ausrüstung als etwas ein oder andere
aber jeder macht im grunde genommen was
er will und die verdienen sich eine
goldene nase an den link und deswegen
heißt sondervermögen ein
sozialdemokratischer friedens kanzler
sorgt dafür dass wir äußerer sicherheit
innere sicherheit und sozialer reformen
gemeinsam machen können das kann so
ziehen die vor weihnachten von dem ich
wollte nur sagen also so ganz nah wir
haben in europa 28
rüstung ohne amerika als russland ja
also es ist nicht so als wir nackt da
stimmten vor dem sonderform irgend ja
das will ich noch mal sagen das ist
nicht so als hätten wir gar nicht nur
radio bremen hat das sondern die
bundesrepublik des arguments 16 jahre
alt ist wer war eigentlich wie hieß das
mal ganz früher worunter spiegel
-herausgeber auch noch in den rankings
sind bedingt abwehrbereit und
wahrscheinlich das wort bedingt schon
gar nicht mehr ganz zu treffen
also der sondervermögen finde ich völlig
in ordnung und es ist in der tat ein
weckruf gewesen
putin das hat er erreicht er hat ja alle
seine politischen vorstellungen
treten jährlich 1 hat ja wohl gedacht
dass alle welt schläft und sich nicht
wehrt und so lassen wir das mal was mich
bei der ganzen diskussion um
sondervermögen und friedens kanzlei
kriegen auch
stört ist eigentlich dass wir die
debatte viel zu polizist risch führen
und zu wenig wirklich politisch also
erstens es ist sicher richtig dass
deutschland nicht nur im rahmen der nato
oder der eu sondern grundsätzlich auch
wegen der vergangenheit aber die es
gegenüber der ukraine wie dem der
sowjetunion damals ja gleich verheerend
schon aufgerufen ist einem land zu
helfen das überfallen worden ist ohne
dass es dafür irgendein anlass gab die
frage ist auch nicht machen wir das auch
mit militärhilfe denn gegen ein
aggressor kannst du dich nur mit
militärischen mitteln wehren und nicht
mehr nur mit schönen reden für mich ist
der wunde punkt in der ganzen diskussion
dass weder die regierung noch die
opposition noch die medien den mut haben
zu fragen wohin das eigentlich führt
welchen zweck verbinden mir mit welchen
waffenlieferung wie weit können wir
mitgehen wenn die ukraine
natürlich das letzte und einzige recht
hat zu entscheiden jetzt verhandelte ich
oder die verhandelnden nicht wir können
der ukraine nicht diktieren welche
zumutungen bedingungen
auflagen zu akzeptieren hat aber wir
können schon und da bin ich anderer
meinung als der kanzler gestern
zumindest im kopf haben wo wir sagen
freunde macht wenn ihr das wollt aber
nicht mehr mit uns auch nehmen wir mit
unserer hilfe
da sind wir viel freier als die
amerikaner wahrscheinlich wollen wir
keinen verärgern und der botschafter
namik hat erreicht dass wir den mund
nicht mehr auf kriegen die amerikaner
sagen klar was sie wollen sie sagen die
ukraine darf nicht verlieren und
russland muss so geschwächt werden dass
ein solcher überfall so schnell nicht
wieder passieren kann sie sind aber sehr
darauf bedacht dass keine waffen
geliefert werden die sie auch nur
indirekt als kriegspartei ausweisen
nehmen wir das jüngste beispiel die
mehrfach raketenwerfer hochmodernen hat
russland offenbar nicht haben wenn man
sie richtig munitioniert auch eine
reichweite von 100 bis 200 kilometern
die auflage ist die kriegen nur munition
die maximal 70 kilometer weit geht das
heißt nur für die abwehr im donbass
benutzt werden kann nicht für
irgendwelche ja sagen wir mal der läufer
die dann auf russischem gebiet ein
schlagen und das ist für mich schon
wichtig wir wissen doch alles am ende
entscheidend waffen nicht die kriege
sondern irgendwann ist ein punkt wo du
verhandeln muss meine reso und ja moment
wir diskutieren das aber nicht weil wir
dann immer sagen wir können der ukraine
nichts vorschein und wir können auch mal
darüber diskutieren dass
er sagt zu recht wie ich übrigens finde
wir reden über ökonomische finanzieller
humanitäre politische diplomatische auch
über militärische aber die militärische
hilfe ist wir versuchen der kokain sich
zu verteidigen hier schließe strikt aus
dass deutschland den krieg hineingezogen
was die nato involviert wird wir wollen
dass der krieg nicht eskaliert er redet
von seinem amtseid schaden vom deutschen
volk abzuwenden das heißt übersetzt was
mit wasser auch sagen auf der straße
auch sagen bitte keinen krieg wir wollen
den nicht haben als die ukraine gesagt
hat macht eine flugverbotszone über der
ukraine haben wir auch klipp und klar
nein dazu gesagt bei mir wurst herr
stegner das ist das erste mal zu es ist
alles bekannt es ist aber offenbar keine
einer die linie die außenministerin hat
jetzt gesagt die ukraine muss gewinnen
ich frage mich was ist dann ja aber das
ist ja genau das problem also ich mag
thematisieren und denke auch dass wir
haben ja inzwischen auch ich glaube
tatsächlich erst mal dass sich die
diskussion inzwischen ein bisschen
gedreht hat ja in der new york times im
wall street journal dass nämlich genau
auch vor allen dingen amerikanische
strategen mölsheimer wissen ja wie auch
immer inzwischen sagen moment mal was
heißt denn gewinnen übrigens auch
deutsche generäle herr kujat einige die
artikel haben sagen das ist nicht auf
dem schlachtfeld zu entscheiden wir
müssen genau wir müssen über
verhandlungen nachdenken über eine
friedensordnung oder garantien wir
müssen das problem ist nicht die
position das problem ist in die
etiketten die verteilt werden richtig
falsch gut und böse wenn putin verstehe
oder kriegshetzer und darum geht es
natürlich nicht so ich glaube ich
persönlich finde krieg furchtbar dass
wahrscheinlich so etwas passiert wir
haben menschen umgebracht frauen
vergewaltigt leute flüchten zerstörung
jeden tag stellungskrieg hört sich
harmlos an um das heißt zerstörung viele
viele tage und deswegen heißt es nicht
so zufrieden um jeden preis aber was
heißt schon das feuerpause humanitäre
hilfe waffen rio entweder haben müssen
und wir helfen zur verteilung deswegen
ist der satz den oder schuld sagen und
ich übrigens auch die ukraine darf den
krieg nicht verlieren dass sie die
perspektive des angegriffenen wo es dann
darf den krieg krieg nicht gewinnen dass
die perspektive des angreifers die
anderen formulierung finde ich schwierig
weil die nämlich kriegsziel wir
definieren die womöglich ganz anderer
art sind und das kann man nicht wollen
das kann man auch nicht richtig finden
und am ende übrigens in russland auch
bleiben russland ist nicht gleich
problem und wir haben es auch mit
anderen diktaturen zu tun herr stegner
das ist alles natur ansatz mein ansatz
ist dass diese debatte bei uns nicht
wirklich ehrlich geführt
im grunde
in einer ganz anderen abrechung direkt
zurück und dann geht es direkt weiter
mit dem ansatz von herrn bremer